دكتوره عائشه عبد الرحمن بنت الشاطئ
والمفكره الكبيره
محمد صلاح
لاعب الكره المصري العالمي
كمان علي مصطفى مشرفه
اينشتاين العرب وعالم الذر
ودكتور زاي حواس عالم الاثار والمصريات
الكبير واخيرا دكتور احمد زويل صاحب جائزه
نوبل في الكيمياء
الاسماء دي كبيره ومعروفه بس تفتكروا ايه
الحاجات المشتركه اللي ما بينهم
العامل المشترك بين كل النجوم دي ان هم
بداوا مسيره نجاحهم من اماكن متواضعه
وبسيطه بعيدا عن اضواء العاصمه وقدر
يوصلوا بنجاحهم لابعد حدود العالميه
مركزيه الشغل والفرص دي حاجه صعبه ومن
اكبر المشاكل اللي بتواجهنا كلنا لكن ده
مش معناه انك ما تقدرش ان انت تنجح في
مكانك ومكانك دوت يكون نقطه قوه ويزق اكل
قدام ويكون انطلاقك نحو الحياه
وده يخليني اطرح عليكم شويه اسئله
هل من الممكن يا جماعه ان اكون بعيد عن
اضواء وشهره ومجد العاصمه وانجح واوصل
للعالميه وانا اللي انور بنجاحي اي مكان
ده سؤال والاسماء دي كانت امثله لناس
اثبتت ان نجاح مش بيعتمد على المكان ولكن
بيعتمد على من يمتلك مقومات النجاح وبيسعى
له من الاخر انت العنصر الاساسي والجاذب
للنجاح بتعبك واجتهادك واصرارك عليه
خلينا متفقين ان من اهم مفاتيح النجاح هي
ثقتك بنفسك لكن الثقه دي لازم يصاحبها
العلم والخبره والا انت ممكن تقع على وشك
من اول تحدي
والمراحل الطبيعيه لبناء خبراتك وانجازاتك
وعلاقتها بالناس دي لها قصه حلوه جدا احب
ان انت تعرفها وتحطها في دماغك
لانها بتحصل لينا في بدايه اي كارير وهنا
محتاج احكي لكم على
خلينا نشوف ايه هي بدايه او مراحل
نبدا بالمرحله الاولى ودائما في بدايه اي
موضوع عندك زي شغل جديد او بروجكت او
خلينا نقول دخلنا الكليه عندك تحدي جديد
بسبب الحماس هتلاقيك داخل دخله الشخص
الواو بصفه عاليه جدا في النفس بس المشكله
انك مش عارف اي حاجه عن الموضوع اللي انت
مقبل عليه والمرحله دي كلنا بنشوفها
وعارفين بس انا بسميها اني اجهل اني اجهل
مانيش عارف حاجه وداخل على طول تلاقي
الثقه عاليه جدا وفي المرحله التانيه
وبمجرد ما تكتشف ان الموضوع طلع كبير عليك
هتلاقي ثقتك بنفسك تبتدي تقل تدريجيا وانك
محتاج شغل ودراسه ومجهود هتقول هنا ده
الموضوع ده طلع كبير عليا قوي ده الناس
اللي في الشغل دولت اشطر مني واقوى مني
والكليه دي انا شكلي مش هقدر اكمل عليها
وبعد ما كل الافكار دي
بتيجي قدامك هتلاقي ان انت محتاج تحضر
نفسك وتاهلها وتعرف ايه اللي ناقصك عشان
تكمله
المرحله دي بنقول عليها اني اعلم اني اجهل
وهنيجي بعد كده للمرحله الثالثه واللي انت
فيها بتتفرم حرفيا وبتشتغل على نفسك
وبتكمل اللي ناقصك وهنا هتلاقي ثقتك
هتبتدي تدريجيا كمان تزيد حتى بدون ادراك
منك وده ببساطه لان القبور بدات تمشي زي
ما انت بتخطط وحتى لو وقعت انت هتقوم
وهتكمل انك عارف السبب وبنسمي المرحله دي
اني اجهل اني اعلم
وهنيجي للمرحله الاخيره اللي نفسنا كلنا
نروح عليها على طول بس ما ينفعش وهي مرحله
النضج واكتمال المعرفه وفي المرحله ديت
انت بتكون بقيت بروفيشنال في مجالك يعني
هتلاقيك كده زي ميسي او رونالدو بلغه
الكوره وبنسميها مرحله جني السمار لانك
هنا هتلاقي الدنيا بدات تمشي اسهل وهتطلع
نتائج باقل الامكانيات وتقدر هنا تكون
قدوه للي حواليك وتكون مصدر الهام ليهم
وعن حق واستحق والمرحله دي احنا بنقول
عليها اني اعلم اني اعلم انا بقيت فاهم
وعارف ودارس كويس بس خلي بالك محتاجين هنا
نكون عارفين المراحل دي كويسه قوي وما
نستعجلش لانك لو نطيت من المرحله الاولى
بالثقه العاليه المفرطه دي للمرحله بتاعه
ميسي بدون تعب او مجهود انت ممكن تقع على
وشك حتى لو كانت البدايات شكلها مبهر
وجميل
انت محتاج تمر بالمراحل ديت وتدي لكل حاجه
فيها حقها عشان لما توصل لهدفك والنجاح
النجاح ده يستمر
ودايما خليك عارف ان المراحل دي كلها
هتتكرر كل مره كل لما تخش على ظرف جديد بس
البدايه المره دي هتكون اسهل واقوى وده
بسبب الخبره اللي انت اكتسبتها مع الوقت
طيب خلينا هنا بقى نتكلم على شويه حاجات
هي ممكن تساعدك على الانجاز وممكن تفرق
معك زي ما فرقت معي على المستوى الشخصي
احب اعرفكم انا واحد من الناس اللي بتنسى
بسرعه جدا يعني ذاكرتي مش رقميه خالص انا
ممكن اتريق على نفسي اقول ذاكره السمكه
انا ما بفتكرش انا اكلت ايه امبارح الحمد
لله بس واحده من الحاجات اللي اثرت وفرقت
معي جدا اني ما انساش هي التدولس
حاجه ممكن تبين ان هي عاديه وبسيطه
وبنشوفها على طول لكن بالنسبه لي هي العكس
من كده تماما
عايز اسالكم هو في حد هنا بيحلم او بيتخيل
يعني مش ساعات تكون خارج كده مع اصحابك
وتقول لنفسك ايه انا عايز اروح الجيم ده
انا عايز اخس ده انا عايز اكل كلنا بنقول
كده كلنا تمام وكمان بعد كده تبدا ترسم في
خيالك انك فعلا رحت الجيم ودفعت الفلوس
وكمان معك بيرس ده فعلا شويتين تلاته
وكمان تتخيل ان انت خسيت وبتبص على صورك
والناس كمان بتسقف لك وتيجي بعدها بيومين
ايه اللي بيحصل فلاك انت اساسا ما عملتش
اي حاجه ولا بدات تمام الفكره هنا ببساطه
ان بترتب لك افكارك وبتحولها لحاجه ملموسه
قدامك بتشوفها على طول وده بيفرق كتير في
حياتك اليوميه عشان كده انا بتمنى ان يكون
عندك كمان اتنين
الاولى للاهداف اليوميه تبقى موجوده على
طول وتشتغل بها وتنجز بيها واحده تانيه
يكون حاطط فيها احلامك وتكون حاطط فيها
اللي انت عايز تعمله
بعيده المدى
وهتلاقيه هنا لو خلصت وعملت عليها ضن
هتكون عندك حافز انك تنجز وتعمل اللي بعده
وهي دي ببساطه هي فكره
دو ان
طيب خلينا هننتقل هنا لحاجه اكتر لو
عايزين نفكر بذكاء اكتر
نعمل ايه خليني احكي لكم حكايه حلوه شويه
وهي قصه البسله مع فالفريتو وباريتو حد
عارف قصه البسله دي
باريتو ده يا جماعه كان محاسب او راجل
بيعمل في مجال الاحصائيات ولاحظ من
المزارعين اللي بيحصدوا محصول البسله في
ايطاليا ان 20% من اللي بيزرعوا البسله هم
اللي بيحصلوا على 80% من المحاصيل الجيده
وبالتالي 80% من الارباح والراجل ده
استغرب قوي من النتيجه دي لكن بعد شويه
تحليل وملاحظه طلع لنا الراجل الاقتصادي
دوت بنظريه بتقول 80% من النتائج جايه من
عشرين في الميه من الاسباب وقال لك كمان
انك لو جيت طبقت النظريه ديت على كل حاجه
تقريبا هتلاقيها شغاله يعني مثلا هتلاقي
ان عشرين في الميه من الناس هم اللي معاهم
80% من الفلوس
هتلاقي ان 20% من اصحابك ودايره معارفك هم
اللي انت حقيقي بتتبسط معهم وهم السند وقت
لشده وهتلاقي ان التمانين في الميه
التانيين انت ممكن تستغنى عنهم والدنيا
تمشي عادي خالص مش هيحصل حاجه
من هنا نقدر نقول ان انا محتاجك هنا تفكر
بذكاء اكتر وتختار في كل حاجه من الاهم
للمهم في كل حاجه انت بتعملها
خلينا نقول
دومورس وهي دي الايه تقدر تطبقها على كل
حاجه حتى لو عايز تطبقها على اللي احنا
لسه كنا بنقولها هتلاقي ان حاجتين او
تلاته من الليستري اليوميه بتاعتك لو انت
عملتهم اول انت حققت 80% من التذكره اللي
انت المفروض تعملها وده ببساطه لانهم
الاكثر اهميه
ايه رايكم فكر كده وقول لي ده ممكن يمشي
ولا لا
طب هنا خلينا ننتقل لخطوه كمان عشان تقدر
تحقق النجاح وتتغلب على مشاكل المركزيه
وهي ان احنا نفكر شويه بره الصندوق ودايما
بنسمع الكلمه دينك اوبوكس يعني خليك دايما
مختلف ومش شبه حد في حياتك بشكل عام
التفكير بره الصندوق اصلا معناه ان يكون
عندك بوكس يعني يكون عندك خطه وهدف واضح
تكون عارف انت عايز تعمل ايه
وتكون فيها بتبص لورقتك مش لورقه غيرك
ومثالي هنا للتفكير بره الصندوق هي مهنتي
اللي انا بحبها ومخليها هوايتي عشان اقدر
اتقدم فيها واعمل فيها كل اللي انا عايز
اعمله وهي طب الاسنان هتلاقي هنا نسبه
كبيره
من دكاتره الاسنان شغالين في حته صغيره
قوي وهي ايه هي البق ايوه البق ومش قادر
اقول لك على كميه العلم والتكنولوجيا اللي
موجوده حاليا في مجالنا بتساعدنا ان احنا
نقوم بشغلنا تجاه مرضانا على النحو الامثل
بس انا عايز اقول يا جماعه ان الدنيا كلها
مش جوه البق انت محتاج كدكتور اسنان ان
انت تبص على الصوره الكبيره والصوره
الكامله عشان تقدر توصل للتشخيص السليم
وعشان كده بحب دايما ان انا اسميها زي ما
دكاتره الاسنان دول هو فينك اوت سايد ذا
بوق
واحده من اهم خطوات التفكير بره الصندوق
من وجهه نظري ان انت تدعم مجال دراستك
بعلم كبير زي علم الاداره وده هيساعدك ان
انت تتقدم في شوك في شغلك بشكل سريع وقوي
يعني زي ما هتزود خبراتك بشكل تقني او
تكنيكال في مجال تخصصك عايزك كمان تزود
خبرتك بشكل اداري او مناجيريا وهتلاقي هنا
الامثله كتير قوي وهتلاقيها بتيجي قدامك
يعني مثلا مش كل الناس الشاطره ومن
الاوائل ايام الكليه هم اشطر ناس في
الحياه العمليه
انت هنا مش محتاج شطاره وعلم نظري بس لا
انت محتاج تكون اجتماعي كويس واداري فاهم
ومع الوقت انت محتاج الخبره والفلوس هنا
دي دايره نجاح محتاجين ان هي تكتمل هتلاقي
مثلا دكتور قوي وشاطر لكنه ما طورش من
شغله فهتلاقي عيادته مش شغاله مثلا لان
العياده مش نظيفه او ان السكرتيره مثلا مش
بتدي مواعيد مظبوطه ودي هنا انا بشوفها
مشكله اداره ملهاش خالص مشكله دكتور
المنافسه القويه اللي موجوده في مجالنا
دلوقتي بيتحتم عليك ان انت دايما تتحرك
بشكل مختلف من الاخر خليك مختلف وبي
طب هاجي هنا لسؤال تاني وكبير هو انا حتى
لو فكرت بره الصندوق زي ما انت بتقول هو
انا ينفع انجح لوحدي هل ينفع اكون حد زي
زويل او او محمد صلاح انا عايز اعرفك ان
حتى الاشخاص دي بدايه مشوارهم بتكون من
عندهم لكن عشان يحققوا النجاح الكبير اللي
انت بتشوفه قدامك ده بيعتمد على حاجات
اكبر بكتير من النجاح الفردي
انت هنا مش بتتكلم عن شخص انت بتتكلم عن
مؤسسه كبيره ووراها تيم اكبر شغال على
دعمهم وعلى نجاحهم فدائما عشان تنجح وتكبر
بجد مش هتعرف تنجح لوحدك لان الاتحاد
دايما قوه لوحدها ما تسقفش والمنافسه اللي
موجوده في صور العمل محتاجه لفكره التيم
ورك او العمل الجماعي عشان تقدر تكون
موجود وتكمل وتستمر لقدام وهنا اقول لك
مثلا انك محتاج تنزل وتشتغل الاول في مكتب
وتكون جزء من تيم كبير قبل ما تقرر تفتح
شركتك هقول لك مثلا لو عايز تفتح عياده
صغيره ولا تفتح
عياده وتكون جزء من ميجا سنتر كبير يكون
فيه كل التخصصات الطبيه
ومن هنا هقول لك من وجهه نظري طبعا ان
الاندماج والكيم ورك هيكون تاثيره اسرع
واقوى انت ينفع تنجح لوحدك لكن عشان تنمو
وتتقدم لقدام هيساعدك جدا
وهنا انا محتاج اتكلم كمان عن حاجه مهمه
جدا وهي اصول فكره الشراكه وايه اللي
يخليها شراكه ناجحه يعني مثلا من البدايه
انت محتاج تخطط لمشروعك من البدايه
للنهايه بكل التفاصيل من البدايه مش في
النص او مش في اللاف
الاتفاقات لازم تكون مكتوبه حتى لو كنت
هتشارك حد من اهلك او من صحابك
ومهم جدا قبل ما ندخل في شراكه لازم نكون
متفقين هنخرج ازاي من قبل ما ندخل لو
احتاجنا لده
لو انت لو انت فرض من منظومه محتاجك تتعلم
ازاي تشتغل بشكل ابداعي مع الناس اللي
حواليك ما تشتغلش لوحدك ولو هتفكر تكون
قائد للتيم دوت فانت محتاج تكون ليدر
للناس دي عشان تعرف تساعدك وتقدرك كمان
ومن هنا انا محتاج اقول ان التي
خلينا بقى هنتكلم عن حاجه ممكن هتجمع لك
كل اللي فات دوت وتربطه مع بعض برباط وثيق
وهي من اهم الحاجات وهي الاساس
انا عايز اسال هنا سؤال هو انا عشان انجح
واوصل انا لازم اتخلى عن مبادئي واخلاقي
وكمان اخليهم عرفهم وده بيحصل كتير
على العكس من ده تماما وبقول ان ديه من
اهم الامور لان الالتزام باخلائيات مهنتك
هو مسئوليتك في شغلك حتى ضد منافسيك وكمان
مسؤوليتك تجاه المجتمع والكوميونت اللي
انت عايش فيه
الاخلاقيات هنا هتضمن لك ان انت تمشي على
ارضيه ثابته ولو كان معها عوامل النجاح
اللي احنا اتكلمنا عليها قبل انا هضمن لك
نجاح يستمر معك
خليني اقول لك في الاخر ان مركزيه الفرص
دي مشكله لكثير مننا في بدايه حياته وبدل
ما يكون طموحك انك تسافر من هنا لمدينه
كبيره او للعاصمه انا عايز بطموحك الكبير
تسافر لابعد من العاصمه وتحقق النجاح
الاكبر في يوم من الايام
اتمنى ان انتم تكونوا وسط الناس دول
بشكركم شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]